Don't get angry josé a person can come here
yes,
and being a foreigner and not being an immigrant for example,
kasogi arrived here on a yacht with the golden omens.
This is not an immigrant,
what a difference it makes.
that one has money the other does not,
of course,
but people like you always think that those who do not have money are
poor and those who come from abroad are immigrants and this is not the case.
he who has no money is poor for sure there he is but apart from that
if he came from abroad he is an immigrant for you
messi was not an immigrant he was a soccer player
not an immigrant eh
if he doesn't even know how to speak Catalan but what
a problem he had to know how to speak Catalan or
Spanish ah it doesn't matter that social integration please
coming to Catalonia to commit a crime is not being an immigrant so when
people say immigrants come to commit a crime lie in case I was not an
immigrant because I was rich bonomi was not an immigrant because he came to
study as I went to other countries and the criminal who comes here to
commit a crime is not an immigrant the immigrant is the one who comes from
one country to another to improve his standard of
living by working that is an immigrant.